[موسيقى]
خمسه احزاب ايرانيه معارضه كرديات تنشط في
المهجر اهم
الديمقراطيه الكردستانيه الايرانيه
المعارض حزب قوميه يقول انه ليس متشددا
ولم انفصاليا نحن اليوم في جبل الحلقه
الاولى
في هذا الجبل على بعد كيلو متر واحد من
الحدود الايرانيه
[موسيقى]
وسط جبال كردستان العراق يتحصل مقاتلون
معارضه الايرانيه لكنها لا تحجب رؤيه
ورقابه النظام
مرحبا بكم كاول وسيله اعلام تصل الى هذا
المكان نحن قريبون من الحدود الايرانيه
وهي منطقه تتعرض باستمرار لتهديد الطائرات
المسيره والصواريخ الايرانيه
تتهم طهران الحزمه الديمقراطي الكردستاني
الايراني المعارض لدعم المظاهرات الاخيره
اثاره الشغب انطلاقا من اراضي العراق تهمه
النفاهه الحزب لكن الحرس الثوري استمر في
شان ضربات متتاليه على مواقعه ومخابئه في
كردستان العراق
[تصفيق]
هذه صور حصريه لقناه العربيه تظهر القصف
الذي شنوه النظام الايراني على مواقع
الحزب في نوفمبر الماضي
حاول النظام تقويض الانتفاضه المدنيه عبر
جرنا الى صراع العسكري
كان الحزب الديمقراطيه كردستانيه الايراني
حجر اساسي اول دوله كرديه في مهبد
الايرانيه عام
1940 قبل ان تسقط يعود الحزب للمشاركه في
الثوره الايرانيه ضد الشهره لم تنتهي
القصه هنا طويت صفحه الشاه وفتحت صفحه
الخميني
عام
1979 فتوى ضد من سماهم بالمتمردين الاكراد
وكان يقصد حينها الاحزاب الكرديه
الايرانيه المعارضه التي طالب الديمقراطيه
والحكم الذاتي منذ ذلك الحين بدات هذه
الاحزاب صراعا مع السلطه صراع دفع بعضهم
الى مغادره البلاد واقامه معسكرات في
كردستان العراق
للاحزاب الكرديه الايرانيه هنا مكاتب
ومقرات تنشط فيها سياسيا كما لها مخابئ
ومواقع للتدريب على السراحه ان كانت تشدد
على ان المواجهه المسلحه مع النظام مؤجله
للاهلي
طبعا امل ولا اجبر على استخدام سلاحي ولكن
اذا اضطررنا الى ذلك فسنستخدم الاسلحه ليس
فقط ضد الحرس الثوري الايراني ولكن ضد اي
شخص يريد سلب حريتنا
[موسيقى]
العربيه الحدود العراقيه الايرانيه